josh is here put some respect on his
name everybody
what's up what's up carlos how's it
going
i'm good so but first elimination
challenge win but i mean like the first
elimination challenge win
right you were you got pretty emotional
how'd that feel
it felt so good honestly this is my
fourth season and
it at that point it was kind of like i
was against myself
because like all the doubt and all the
fear of going into elimination
um after losing three seasons in a row
um it was rough but i think that like
i've gotten so comfortable with being
down in the sand and being in
eliminations that this season i went
into it
kind of wanting to go in early as soon
as i heard the goal the skull twist
again i just wanted to go in and earn it
as soon as possible
and uh yeah i feel like it just gave me
this confidence of just like
not really giving and just going for it
yeah
yeah there's so many things you can play
with your head in this game like
and not least of all your own attitude
towards yourself and your
your like your record of wins and losses
um when when tj was like oh there's
actually going to be a puzzle challenge
first like what went through your head
were you because it looked like you were
low-key
a bit shocked about that were you
worried at all yeah so at that point we
were
we kind of so once we saw last week
jay and leroy go up against each other
and they repeated the eliminations we
knew that there was going to be like a
repetitive thing and then we're going to
do that again
so i kind of knew the elimination that i
was going into and then when he threw
that
blind side with the puzzle i was a
little shocked but i felt confident i
was
like i think for me it's all mental i do
with anxiety and
with my eliminations from the past i
panicked instead of staying calm and
like executing
i would go into straight panic and just
like you know go crazy a little stir
crazy so i think
just staying calm uh helped me a lot and
i felt really really
i just felt it in my gut that i was
gonna you know uh
do well in it and i was really confident
just in myself that night so yeah i'm
glad it worked out
would have sucked to lose that damn
shuffle a puzzle like that but yeah it
worked out
those slide puzzles drive me crazy the
fact that you did that so fast was
actually super impressive
yeah uh i went out a little fun fact i
went out on a puzzle my first season so
i legit practice puzzles all the time i
like download it on my phone i have
little puzzle boards that i'm always
playing so yeah that's one thing that i
feel like i've gotten better at but i
haven't had
a chance to kind of like show my puzzle
skills lately but uh yeah that was fun
that was a that was a good limb
the second half though was a bit wild
too like i i'm wondering
because watching it i have to admit man
it looked like it was going on
forever for you and i know that feeling
too when you're just like
what is happening like why can't i get
this is it was it just stretched out for
us viewers or did it really feel like
forever for you
i honestly think it was stretched out um
i don't even think that elimination took
five minutes if i'm being honest with
you
it was pretty quick but uh yeah at first
i did struggle because i did engage how
heavy the balls were so i was like okay
i've had medicine balls before like
what 20 30 pounds i'm not gonna lie it
was they were like 50 70 pound medicine
balls
so trying to throw them overhead was not
the move
uh so yeah i struggled a bit and as you
guys saw but i think once i got the
groove of it it was
pretty like straightforward after that
and it was pretty easy yeah
but the peanut gallery also doesn't help
sometimes like how do you shut out
because you obviously have people
they're supporting you right yeah like
the
the the big brother team is supporting
you yeah but then you've also got some
people that are maybe not so
nice oh dude and they didn't they cut
devin literally talking
to me the whole elimination like when i
tell devin afterwards on my call brawl
nexus because devon was going
in i mean that's what he's good at the
guy runs his mouth
uh but he was going in the whole
elimination trying to throw me off
talking throwing my record out there
uh so yeah that was hard but i think
that
uh like i said i was so locked in and of
course i have my good friends with him
big brother and we just had such a
strong alliance that i knew like if i
came back into the game
i was pretty much gonna be set for the
rest of the game because we had so many
numbers
that doesn't even show on the edit like
we had all of cam and leroy's side which
was a niece and nanny darrell
and then i had all the big brother so i
knew if i got that win i was pretty much
set up to make that final um i was in a
really good spot if i would have got
back in the game so that's all
like hearing fessy and casey and amber b
just cheering for me that's all the
motivation i needed
and the alliance is tight like it's
tight like you guys are
it seems like nothing's gonna challenge
you guys and but even the even the idea
of like trying to break you up and
people going against you
is a hard idea like that's bad like it's
a bad strategy are you confident that
you guys are gonna ride it through
together
oh yeah for sure i think the biggest
blessing that i've had
this season was having uh such a tight
bond with bessie and casey like
being in a game like the challenge where
everybody's out for everyone i think the
biggest thing is loyalty and
obviously they know that i'm loyal to
them but i think that this season we're
real friends outside of the show and it
just
we built a stronger bond in there and
then adding amber b and even lolo a
little bit working with us we were so
strong as a like an alliance
that um you know even though people may
not give us credit and they say that big
brother shady and all this stuff i think
that we're one of the strongest most
loyal alliances in the game
so uh besides cam and leroy of course
but yeah they
they definitely had my back and i had
there so it was it was just a good team
to have in there
yeah but you guys have an advantage like
you already know how to play this part
of the game
oh yeah that's it yeah yeah for sure and
you know i think like with the whole
political side again we don't get enough
credit but i think that
with you know casey such a strong
political player as you saw in the
in the episode amber b was kind of
pulling strings within the rookies so
everybody was like kind of doing their
own thing and protecting our core
alliance and
it benefited all of us and moving
forward i hope you guys get to see that
more
like within the edit yeah so now
when it comes to the gold skulls it's
going to be all about stealing
um yeah who who's a threat like who's a
legit threat
right now i mean everybody up there that
doesn't have it you have
corey that makes a final back-to-back
every time great competitor darrell a
champ
ct a champ you got three guys that are
heavy hitters
um but one thing that i was confident
about was like all right if i go into
this elimination
then i know that i just saw a puzzle
hopefully it's gonna be something
physical and i'm not saying that i can
beat those guys
but i am confident i'm six one two forty
like i am confident if it is a
headbanger
that i can kind of hold my own um but i
know that all three of them
all three of those guys are beasts and i
knew that at some point my name was
gonna get called again i just had to be
ready
and fingers crossed that it would be
something that i would be good at like
you know a hall bra or something like
that or i've never gone into a
headbanger
and all i've wanted was to like prove
myself within like my challenged career
to like have a headbanger so that's all
i could hope for
moving forward in the game oh we see you
talk about
um why you're doing this and you get you
know again you get emotional you talk
about your parents
and uh wanting to do this for them
yeah um why why is that such an
important thing for you like obviously
your you know your family is important
to you but can you describe to us the
feeling
that motivates you yeah um you know they
they show a little bit about it but um
with my family i'm a first generation
american so my parents came from cuba
literally with
zero dollars um and just my dream like
growing up seeing their struggle and
seeing everything they did and the way
they provided for me and my siblings
sending us to college
never made an excuse to just give us the
best life i live with that in my heart
like yeah i won big brother and i made
great money after the show
but they've also been so selfless and
like letting myself set myself up like
doing things for me and my future where
it's like now
i want to win one to be able to like all
right you guys don't have to worry about
nothing and
just that financial security of like
them not having to just bust their ass
day in and day out with their um you
know business
and i i think that that's something that
i want to continue to share more about
and just be more open because i feel
like
as a first generation we all struggle
you know we all come into this country
and we go through so many things that
a lot of people don't talk about or know
but uh uh i'm i'm very blessed that i
had the opportunity to be on tv
like that in itself is a huge
accomplishment for
me and my parents um and just like i
hope
in the future i could you know become a
challenge champion and then give them
that life they've always dreamt of yeah
yeah no you got it you're about to give
me your money
um well you're also like the first big
brother champ of you know your
background
as well and i know like i know if it's
similar with you as it is with me and my
family but i carry a lot of family
responsibility when i do things right
like i care my family's name
and i think you feel the same thing is
it important to you that you actually
represented well
for your family too
um i think it's more so the thing is
like my family is very supportive in
everything that i do and obviously
within reality tv
and the shows that i've done i've had it
i've had my fair share of arguments and
all that stuff so it is hard
um but i think that yeah for sure i want
to
you know i want to continue to grind and
hustle and come on these shows and
compete and make money to just give back
to them and kind of
you know just show them the appreciation
that i have for them because
they hear it and they see it within my
actions and everything i do but like
i haven't had like that real moment
where i could like you know give back to
them how i want to so
that's the goal that's like my drive in
life just to set my parents up
yeah yeah um when i look at the
landscape of like
reality shows and and diversity and
reality shows right you're on the ones
that have the most diversity
for sure yeah do you ever think about
that in terms of how you're representing
to
how you like you know everyone that's
watching can relate to someone that's
competing
so if i'm being completely honest with
you i never really looked at it from
that perspective because i've never
i don't i've never went on tv like i'm
gonna be a role model if anything i've
shown
the good the bad and like all of me and
that's why i think i've had so much
success and
continue getting callbacks because you
see all like you get the real me
um but now definitely after like what's
gone on in the world this past year and
just seeing everything and getting so
many messages from people
last season they showed a clip of me
like talking with my family in spanish
and i didn't even realize that impact
and how many people just latinos had
started writing to me and reaching out
and
definitely from now on i do want to just
carry myself knowing that i am kind of
representation for latinos and
and you know kind of do a better job at
controlling my emotions because we are
we are
we are known for being a little hot
tempered um but but yeah i think that
it is pretty dope that you know being
the first latino to win big brother to
then compete on the challenge and be
that representation it's a huge blessing
so
i'm grateful for it but it's unique in
the space too of like
being famous because people get to see
all those size of you and then and they
get to form their opinion that way like
there's nothing
that's hidden it's not like you're just
pretending to be a happy dude all the
time
that must be cool all the time too
because you get to you know like you
said i might control this side of myself
but you also get to show that side of
yourself
right i agree um yeah
it's it's so it's hard to balance
because i feel like
the fan base and the audience has only
seen me in competition shows so they
don't
really they see that side of me and
obviously i'm a competitive person and
when you're in an element like the
challenge and in that game
everything's heightened everything's way
more intense so it does bring out sides
of all of us that aren't the best
qualities of our character you know but
i think that
um you know if i was on a show like
where you would follow my day today
people would see that i'm way more chill
in real life um and just
i don't know i think that for sure like
you said i'm going into future seasons i
do
carry this responsibility of just like
just kind of representing
and and putting on for my latinos and
just yeah
yeah um i want to talk to you about uh
all-stars for a minute because we
you've talked a bit about it before
about like it not working out
um being disappointed can you walk us
through like
what went down because people were
obviously still looking forward to
seeing you
yeah um so with all stars i mean i i'll
be completely real with you so i
got reached out early on from march i
knew that it was going to be an all-star
season
so i was going back and forth kind of
negotiating between
all-stars and challenge and i ended up
going with all-stars and the producers
over at mtv
respect at the challenge respected it
and they were very supportive
and they understood it i go into support
i'll go into sequester i was
in there 15 days and i did get covered a
month before so
i did get sick i was sick for like two
weeks it was
the worst like i felt the worse i've
ever in my life
um so i was sick but i thought at that
point i was fine because i took we had
to take rapid tests right before we left
negan uh yeah they came back negative
and i took like three consecutive
negatives
while i was in lockdown quarantined
doing the photo shoots and doing
everything and kind of setting up
i had a positive come back and then
another positive come back
and at that point literally a few days
right before i think it was like monday
and the show premiered on wednesday
they dropped me and it was i i went
online and i
put out a tweet and i try to put on this
positive
you know i try to see the blessing of
everything but i was deaf i was
heartbroken like i've been a fan of big
brother
since i was a kid it was the second i
mean you know the first time they'd done
all-stars and years and i was
one of the first locks and it just broke
i was shattered i was i
i wouldn't say depressed but i was
definitely in a depressed date and i was
all alone in la
to then call the challenge a few days
later they accept me back and i go
straight into quarantine the next week
for the challenge so coming into the
season
i was not in a good month i think i
should have taken the season off i'm
glad i did it for so many reasons
because i was kind of able to grow grow
and go through it but
it was so hard being in that being
thrown into a game when i had just went
through that and kind of slammed on the
internet for having kobe
um so it was it was just hard it was a
lot yeah yeah but in a way maybe it was
good because it
you know it got you focused on something
right yeah yeah i i think that
you know while i was in the challenge
house it was really hard
and then just processing that i wasn't
on off like that what everything that
happened with all stars
but i feel like it distracted me and i
wasn't home watching the show which i
wish
i think it would have like seen somebody
in my spot it would have hit me harder
um so now i'm completely over and i'm in
a good space and hopefully god willing i
get the chance to play
big brother again in the future but yeah
that was really that was a tough time
for me for sure yeah we know you're a
fan of uh big brother canada we got
season nine coming up
are you looking forward to anything in
particular is it something you want to
see
oh yeah diversity i just want to see the
i mean they said it i saw a statement
that they made and i follow erisa
and i love iris and just a diverse cast
but just
now go into the gameplay knowing that
they're going to come out with an
audience and try to play up to the fans
screw that just just i like just like
kind of a savage game like a ruthless
game just go
mad and just do whatever you got to do
to win so just
cut through people in there just people
that just like are authentically
themselves and just there to win
just able to do whatever they got to do
to win so yeah
um yeah i'm excited and i'm gonna be
watching i don't know how i'm gonna be
able to stream it but for sure i'm gonna
keep up with uh with this season you're
not looking for stars you're looking for
pure game you want pure
game pure game pure game i don't care if
you come out most hated listen
sometimes you know the villain makes for
good tv so give me some give me some
good tv
yeah right on man yeah it was a pleasure
chatting with you dude congratulations
thank you so much